[inaudible].
Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
February 1st, 2006 Dane, what's going on? There you go.
The first month of the year is out of the way in old Billy BU's bag.
It's been doing really well. All right. Last time I got here,
last time I got hammered was a,
the last day Versie was out here visiting me whatever fucking day that was.
It was like the second or 3rd of January.
And um,
I didn't drink for the rest of the month other than the fact I had eight beers
leftover from the rose bowl.
So I just drank like one a day for eight straight days. Um,
always wanting a second, forget about a third in a ninth beer. But I,
uh, just, I just had one that was it self,
it's not bad for me. You know,
I went like three weeks without drinking and then eight straight days, lol.
He had one beer and then yesterday I didn't have any beer in the fridge.
I might have a Guinness left, but I didn't drink it. So, um,
you know, we were out here. What was Sunday?
It was fucking raining to beat the band.
Is that the fucking expression? The play, the band?
I haven't know what it was fucking pouring out here for like legitimately the
almost the entire day. Um, which is great.
We could probably use about 90 more of those days,
but that was good that that was happening. So, um,
I just fucking stayed home. Didn't do shit. Last time I did Joe Rogan's, uh,
podcast, he gave me some elk meat that he had. Uh,
he fucking killed an elk. He murdered it premeditated.
The man got in his car and said, I'm going to kill a fucking out,
but he didn't know which one, so we can only get them on second degree murder.
And I became an accessory to the murder when I agreed to take some of the
carcass off his heads. Uh, no, he just gave me these two like giant,
like softball sized things that elk and they'd been sitting in my freezer.
So a, I heard the meat's really lean and that it could be a little gamey.
So I just looked up some recipes and there was something there for like elk,
Chile. And um, so I, uh,
I made that yesterday and uh, and it was fucking delicious.
Of course the lovely Nia goes out there and be like, is this done?
This doesn't look done. This doesn't,
I guess I'm just not used to Chile with this like consistency.
This mug looks more like a stew cause there wasn't any tomato paste in.
The recipe was still delicious. It was definitely a little more watery.
So she had to go out and go fuck with the whole thing and I'm eating the one
that I made and I'm enjoying it and she just keeps letting the other room just
kept going, like for thought or whatever. That's fine. I was just like,
will you shut up? It's fine. Fucking time.
I go out in the kitchen,
she fucking nitpicks whatever the hell it is that I'm making,
it's fucking unbelievable. She makes something, I eat it. It's good.
Go out there and go to the fucking spice rack. You know, it's, it's, it's, it's,
it's rude. It's rude. So we got into it,
you know, as we always do, right. Get into it a little bit. Then she laughs,
told me to go fuck myself,
and then she gave me her version of what the tomato paste and you know,
I say say, Oh yeah, I see what you're saying. I like it. You know, that,
guess what I really felt. I felt the first one tasted better.
She thickened it all up with this fucking tomato paste and then made it like
sweeter and uh, you know, did it to the whole fucking pot. So,
you know, if we had a giant pot of it. So I was like, well,
I can handle what the fuck she did to it. If it's just mine.
I got eat the whole pot, so I just rolled with it.
Just one of those times you just sit quietly and you not, yeah. Okay.
That's what you did over there. All right, I'll approve that. You know.
Anyways, um, underrated elk meat.
Got To throw it out there. It's fucking delicious.
So then we fucking sit in there. I take my dog out,
there's a little a break in the, um,
in the, in the weather. So I take my dog around the block and uh,
Blahblahblahblahblah and I come back in and he is like, Hey, you know what?
Why don't you want to have a pot cookie?
Okay.
And I was like, no, I don't. I got the podcast to do, I got some bills,
mail and shit I have to do. She's like, come on, it's fucking raining.
We're not going anywhere. This is a perfect day to have a pot cookies. Like,
I don't like that shit. It gets me too fucked up. I feel like I'm hallucinating,
I don't want to do it. And she goes, no, these are really mild.
These are really mild.
I know everybody out there who fucking consumes those things right now is
laughing. [inaudible] they really mild. So I guy find,
so I fucking eat this thing right.
And it comes on really slow. It's mellow. And on my card I can deal with this,
just sort of just be chilling out and be relaxed and then all of a sudden just
fucking to the moon. Alice, right. I was like fucking tripping.
Not like literally, but it was just like, you know,
I closed my eyes and my feet would feel like they would nine miles away from me,
you know? And uh, that was it.
I took it in the afternoon like around four o'clock by five o'clock.
That was it. The day was over. So now here I am,
I've got a bunch of shit to do and I'm trying to cram this crap in there.
I really don't. I don't like it. Um,
potheads idea of what mild is, is not, you know,
now I'm sure I'm going to get a bunch of fucking,
get a bunch of fucking emails from people going like this.
You want this sativa fucking a Asian infused strain,
a weed man. I just don't give a fuck. Right.
I mean, I was like, just, I was TV just dying,
laughing at everything that fucking came on there.
My wife made some cornbread with the Chili and I started doing like a cornbread
commercial, you know, hey guys, what's better than a, than a bullet Chili.
That's right. A nice piece of cornbread. Hi. Do you know me? Of course. Sure.
We all do. I was just doing that shit and I was the funniest shit ever to me.
And they was looking at me like, what the Fuck's wrong with you? And I'm like,
what do you mean what's wrong with me? You fucking drugged me.
I swear to God. You know what I think it was,
I think the horror of me being around for 24 hours with that weather,
she got like cabin fever and she literally drugged me because she was able to
handle it fine, which is making me think.
She took less and she was just sitting there watching TV and I've seen all this
shit that's making me laugh and she's just sitting there totally quiet.
I was like, I go my bomb and over here she was just like, no, no, no.
I hear what you're saying. I'm just watching the show and I like,
how are you that fucking like,
I'm still a little fucked up right now. 24 hours later,
I don't know.
So anyways, that's why I like alcohol. It slowly comes on,
I know where it's going. It isn't like you grab a beer and you're this,
I wonder what this does. What's the end know this,
this is a mellow drunk and then all of a sudden you get like fucking 20 times
drunk and then you want it to be, I mean, that can start,
that can happen I guess with hard stuff.
Um,
I did, I don't know, I just feel like the amount of fucking edibles,
you have to have to start to understand what they do to you.
It's just not fucking worth it. So, uh, that was my one pot cookie for the year.
But anyways, I haven't had a cigar since the eighth. Um, so I did it.
I'm trying to be too cigar a month guy. And I did it in January.
I had one at the rose bowl and I had one on the eighth and then I got a whole
fucking month ahead of me. So rather than smoking on the first, you know,
I'm just gonna fucking chill here for like a week to 10 days.
And then I figure I got to, I can smoke.
I'm really just taking you through my whole fucking a bad habit schedule.
They on. I um, I was speaking to cookies by the way.
I bought two boxes of girl scout cookies from this lei.
You know,
it's never the girl scout anymore knocking on the door. Thank God.
Thank God with all the,
the A to catch a Predator's they probably got sick of getting the door.
Fuck it slammed in their face. Dig Dog. He opened the door. Hi,
I'm selling girls. Got The door
fucking yelling at your dog. You saw nothing happened. So anyways, um,
now that just sort of sold by adults as far as I know.
So I got two boxes of these fucking things. And, um,
I just finally realized the amount of time that I've always felt like the girl
scouts made the cookies cause they were called girl scout cookies and just
somewhere maybe in the middle of this country around Fort Knox,
like the a,
the United League of American dos girl scouts has their headquarters and they
just had these giant tubs where they just stirred up cookie batter once a year
and they got 'em out. And um,
okay.
After finally thinking about it and looking at the professional packaging, um,
I'm going to go out on a limb here and I, and I want to say, I don't think,
I don't think any girl scouts make any of those fucking cookies.
I think they fucking outsource it. Right.
It's probably made by children, Central America.
They sit there crying, how hard they have to work,
knowing they're never going to get a bite, you know.
And then one of them actually steals a cookie and there's some psychotic
disciplinary action that's taken. Let's Google this shit. Huh? Shall We?
This is like the new segment now. They'll just, you know, back in the day.
She just talk now. I'm actually going to look it up here.
Who makes girl scout cookies?
Okay.
All right. Girl scout cookies. All right,
girl scout cookies or cookies sold by girl scouts. I'll thank you. Thank you.
Wikipedia,
girl scouts of the USA or GS USA as one of its major fundraisers for local
scouts units, members of the girl scouts of America,
but selling cookies since 1917 girls who participate can earn prizes for their
effort. Fuck you. That's my name. Alec Baldwin comes in and screams at them.
All right.
The first cookies sales was by a scouting union missile,
the missile troop in Oklahoma and December,
1917 at their local high school in 1922 girl Scout magazine, the American girls,
the American girls suggested cookie sales as a fundraiser, blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah.
From 33 to 35 country-wise organized cookie sales grew with troops in
Philadelphia, in New York City using the cookie selling model,
so they're cooking their own ones. World War Two.
They sold calendars in 1990 the national council limited the bakeries providing
cookies to just ABC bakeries,
a division of inner Interbake foods. Oh wait,
I skipped over something. The 1953 more cookie recipes were added short breads,
peanut butter sandwich, and thin mints. The classic,
it's like the Beatles, Zeppelin, and the who of cookies.
Six types of cookies of being sold nationwide. Great.
A cookie sale due to the baby boom generation. They needed more.
The Samoa was added in 75. All right, whatever.
So ABC bakers was making in the 1990s and little Brownie Bakers,
little Prouty bakers at division of the key book company.
In 1998 cookie sale awards were instituted with the 2005 trans fat controversy.
The girl scouts move to make the cookies healthier and provide nutritional
information on the box. In 2009, the number of thin myths,
Dosey dose and tag tag alongs in each box was reduced.
Why? And Lemon chalet creams became smaller because of the increasing costs of
ingredients and transportation. All right. So the, they're there.
They try to make it with less, uh, less trans fats.
Here's 10 weird girl scout cookie facts and then we'll get off this fucking
subject. I have dry mouth from that fucking cookie last night. Hey,
when they legalize like,
yeah,
pot at a federal level,
do you think that they'll actually have girl scout like pot cookies?
You know, Jesus Christ. That'll be a field day.
What's happening to this country? And they're selling drugs. All right?
Number one. These cookies are older than your grandmother. That's not weird.
It's not weird to, you can make the original recipe at home.
You can make the original recipe of everything at home. If you know the recipe.
Do you feel like taking a trip back in time and baking some boring stuff? Oh,
this must be one of these hipster sites where they're over everything,
including making fucking cookies.
You can try the authentic or they actually liked making the cookies,
but they're anticipating being insulted.
So what they do is they make fun of themselves first.
So you can authentic original girl scout cookie recipe.
It's not in the recipe recipe,
but they taste better if you dress up as a girl scout when you make them all,
it's a little internet joke. Only two companies make the cookies.
Honey booboo is banned from selling them.
[inaudible]
thin mints are, aren't just delicious. They're mandatory.
I don't know what that means.
There is a cookie queen and she's a master sales woman.
Yeah.
Oh, there's a non sanctioned girl scout cookies. Weed strain. Of course.
Girl scout cookies used to cost less than a quarter.
Everything costs less. There was a cookie shortage during World War II.
Of course. Not every cookie made the grade
a Jesus. That was disappointing. All right.
Can I apologize for the wasting the last fucking 15 minutes you life talking
about girl scout cookies, um,
to anybody watched the NHL Walstad Gay fucking three on three hockey dod.
It was actually pretty entertaining but not quite as exciting as I thought it
was going to be. Cause no one was going to take the body dude.
But it was still cool and obviously seen John Scott score a couple of goals.
That's fucking hilarious that the NHL didn't want him in there after all the
money that they've made on fighting and all this shit that a goon goes through,
you know, the fact that the fans liked him enough to elect him into the game,
right? Daddy gets fucking traded,
set down to the minus and they told them not to show up.
Then he blogged about it like a seventh grade chicken. Everybody went, Dude,
what the fuck? And then he was there and then he scored two goals.
It's like a Hollywood fucking movie. Hey, any non hockey fans?
Did you actually sit down and watch the All Star game?
It's everything that you would've liked. Huh? A zillion fucking goals.
No fighting, nothing.
Physical people smiling after rum running into one another.
Was it dumbed down enough for you? They're fucking who? Peds. Um,
I actually only watched the first period. It's,
it appeared like the first period was only like 10 minutes long.
Is that true or was I under the influence of a pot cookie? Um,
but anyways, all exciting news here. Exciting news for me. Um,
I'm actually doing a Gig in Cheyenne, Wyoming now,
Wyoming is the last state that will fucking,
Billy red face has never performed it. And at this point, um,
I will have performed in all fucking 50 states. And uh,
that being the fact that, I don't know, I have a little debt. OCD, right?
Is that what it is now? I don't know what it is. I just like, you know,
at first I was like, you know what? I'm going to go to every baseball stadium.
Then it became immediately goes,
I'm going to go to every fucking stadium that exists, you know?
So if I start doing stand up and then it becomes, all right, dude,
I've done three states.
It immediately I have to do every state and then it becomes a,
I have to do every continent, you know,
except for like Antarctica or like places that don't want me. Right.
But anyways, I'm going to be a, I'm going to be in Cheyenne, Wyoming.
I'm going to put, first of all, I'm going to be in Denver, Rocky Mountain.
Ha. And please don't bring me any fucking pot cookies. All right.
I don't enjoy the I, I don't, I, okay. I, I just,
it's too much on the 12th and 13th I believe the, uh,
12th and 13th is Wyoming and Denver or Denver, Wyoming. I don't know which one.
And then the 14th is Valentine's Day.
And that's of course when a young people go out because they're not smart enough
to realize that, uh, that you can say, I love you on any day of the year.
You know, what's a great day to go out? Go out on like the 17th, you know,
or the 16th and the 19th or the 21st don't go out right before,
go out after God. After I say this every fucking year, you know,
look at us.
The super bowl this year is on the seventh and the fucking Valentine stays on
the 14th. Now those are two absolutely absolute shit show days.
Now obviously if your own fucking football team is playing in the Superbowl,
you know this, you're gonna want to watch you with a couple of other fans,
right? However,
that doesn't mean that you're going to go to one of those shit show fucking
super bowl party. So like I said, as always, take the fucking game,
let it go for a good 90 minutes. Then you come in, you sit down,
you blow through all the commercials,
you blow through the fucking halftime show.
Fast forward through all of that shit.
And then when the game really starts getting down to it, you know,
you're caught right up. You'll catch up in like the beginning of the, uh,
the fourth quarter. Then you can just kind of watch it in real time.
It's fucking perfect. And you know, blow your whole afternoon.
Oh fuck. Sorry guys. No more pot cookies for me. Um,
and then the, uh, on the 14th, same thing, just wait like two, three days after
when you can get a fucking reservation,
you can go to the restaurant you want to go to and they haven't jacked the
prices up through the fucking roof. Um,
and then you're done. Right.
Okay,
here's a good one, right? Cause guys,
we usually don't get shit on Valentine's Day. So, uh,
I suggest don't get your wife's shit either.
Just take her out to dinner and fucking leave it at that. And if she's like,
I thought you were going to get me something else, just be like,
well did you get me something else? And when she's like, no, you'd be like, ah,
well I paid for dinner. That's it.
And that guarantees that should be in a fucking awful fight on Valentine's Day.
How you like that? Let's see what I'm staring steering you towards.
Um, for the life of me,
Bill Burke coming to Cheyenne Civic Center to 11.
The fuck are you talking about?
That can't be right.
[inaudible]
Bill Barb will perform at the Cheyenne Civic Center in Cheyenne,
Wyoming on Thursday, February 11th. All right, so then on the 12th,
I must be in Denver. Is that right?
Jesus Christ Bell. How do, why don't you fucking know your own goddamn schedule?
Denver, I had to go ski and when I'm out there, you know,
I ski once every 10 years. I really should take a lesson because that,
that is just the a blow your fuck. Yes. The 12th. All right,
so the 11th Thursday I'm in Wyoming and February 12th I'm in Denver.
Ah, that's how it is. Very nice. So there you go.
The Cheyenne Civic Center,
you know they always have fucking rodeos and shit there, right?
What goes on there, Toby? Keith,
Cheyenne Civic Center civic up to be like some old ABA building
images. Jesus Christ. Look at Cheyenne.
This looks like a fucking opera plays there. And Opera Bill and orchestra.
Um, the Cheyenne Civic Center.
Go on to Cheyenne, Wyoming.
What are some of the great things that happened in Wyoming over the years? Huh?
Only thing you always hear is bad stuff isn't that place with a,
with a tight that kid cause he was gay to the fence until he died.
This isn't good. They don't have any sports tapes.
The fuck am I going to Wyoming for Wyoming?
Is this where like Ted Turner can ride his horse all over the place and be like,
I own that.
I'll own that to get off of there or I'll take you out of Yardi,
your basic cable package. Take my, my fucking TV Outta here.
Um, don't ever start any shit with Ted Tourney in Wyoming. All right.
Because he's going to come and arrest you and then he's going to be the judge
and he's going to throw you in. GE owns the whole fucking state. Does he?
I believe he does, right? I don't know. Anyways,
let's get to the fucking rates here for this week. Oh, Billy,
all over the place. All right. What are we got here? The first read.
Oh, look who's back everybody. Sherry's.
Barry's a must be a clam day coming up. Oh yes it is.
Valentine's Day is next week. Finding the right gift can be tricky.
Uh, tell a personal story relating to Valentine's Day. Well, you know,
I think it's bullshit. You know, I always hated it when I was fucking younger.
I think everything's, uh,
overpriced and everybody just sits there looking around at everybody,
you know, and then somebody gets proposed to and they're like, oh my God.
And then, you know,
even if you already proposed through the one year with this still kind of
fucking jealous and sad, you know,
then you just sit there splitting a dessert. That's the part I hate the most.
Just sitting there splitting dessert because that means I've wanted to leave for
at least an hour and 10 minutes. I just feel like you're distant tonight.
Um, oh, here's an example of the story.
Why you give Valentine's Day gifts, getting the wrong gifts,
getting the right gift, horror stories of waiting until the last minute,
et cetera. I don't think you should get them a gift out of the,
you should get them anything more than Sherry's berries.
The fuck are they getting you?
Where is the copy for what the lay is going to get the guy,
this is such a fucking bullshit. This, this, this whole holidays.
Completely fucking sexist. And I, you know, I, you'd like to hear more raw,
a little chatter from the fucking feminist ladies there about this. You know,
why are you taking me out?
Why don't I take you out every other year and then I get you a gift. Come on,
ladies. Let's have an even playing field, right? All right.
You want to give something unique that she'll love,
but you don't want to spend a zillion dollars. You know? You want to say, Hey,
I'm really like you. You know I really like you,
but I'm not quite in love with you yet, but I'd like you to continue fucking me.
What would be a perfect gift? Sherry's berries,
freshly dripped strawberries from Sherry's berries starting at only 1999 it's
over 40% savings. That's less than hookah, and if you don't want,
if you really want hero status, you can double the berries for just 10 bucks.
Just go to berries.com click on the microphone and type in my code.
B. U. R. R. These strawberries are picked at the peak of freshness.
Now they're not. They never are.
They fucking get yanked and then they throw them and they ripen on the truck.
They ripe.
They're all fruit ripens on the fucking truck without the nutrients from the
vine to ensure the best gift experience.
They're huge and dipped in white milk and dark chocolate goodness.
Top with chocolate chips.
Chop nuts and decorative swizzle delivery is always guaranteed. Oh,
we'll get them there. We just don't know when.
Here's the only way to get these amazing balance,
this amazing Valentine's date deal, juicy, huge,
and freshly dip strawberries starting at just 1999 or double the berries.
You fucking whore for $10 more.
Visit berries.com please spell out the word berries.
B. E. R. R. I. E. S. Dot Com.
Click on the microphone on the in the top right hand corner and type in Barbie.
You are r. Go to berries.com. Click on the microphone and enter my code today.
B u. R. R. All right, pro flowers.
Look who's here? Everybody. Little candy and flowers.
You ought to buy an old school outfit. Two little derby, three piece vest,
three piece suit, I should say with the vest. Little pocket watch. All right.
PLO pro, flowers. Sometimes parentheses. Okay.
All the time. It's hard for us guys to say what we feel.
What if there was a gift that said send it for you Jesus.
See how sexist this shit is yet too fucking dumb to say what you thinking.
Why don't we handle it? Why? With a bunch of Shit we ripped out of the ground.
Imagine a gift that was thoughtful, easy,
and she love and that set your message perfectly all in one.
It's a beautiful flowers. They're beautiful like you.
I call that a win on Valentine's Day.
Tell a personal story relating to Valentine's Day. Well,
I always thought it was fucking bullshit.
I always thought it was bullshit in all a day.
You know you pay way too much money and then halfway through some other woman
gets proposed to it. Even if you already proposed to your woman,
she's still look it over though. Like, oh,
I don't feel like I'm the fucking queen of the ball.
They really liked these personal stories. Example,
why you give Valentine's Day gifts, getting the wrong gift. Jesus did the same.
People write this shit.
Pro Flowers are the flower pros that make Valentine's Day easy.
Trust pro flowers and get this year done right.
Pro Flowers is offering my listeners plus any other podcasts.
They advertise on 100 blooms of love plus a free glass vase for just 1999 plus
this week only you'll get free chocolates for when you order for by Friday.
Ah, they're into Sherry's berries. Turf. There's going to be a fucking war.
Go to pro flowers.com and use my code bar B. U. R. R. A.
Pro Flowers is quick and easy and delivers for Valentine's Day.
Deliveries of Valentine's Day is guaranteed pro flowers at guaranteed the last
seven days of your money back. It's a no brainer.
Here's the only way to get amazing Valentines, the amazing Valentine's Day deal,
including the free chocolates. Go to pro flowers.com.
Click on the blue microphone in the top corner. Type in burrow.
That's pro flowers.com. Click on the microphone and type in my code bar.
You must order it by Friday, right midnight in order to get this deal. Wow.
That's going to be an issue, huh? Okay. Cut Right into Sherry's berries.
Sherry's fucking berries. Well, there's only one more here,
so I might as well plow through it. No, no, there's two more. All right.
We'll split it up. We'll split it up. Uh, you know,
I was actually debating watching the Superbowl by myself and doing a little bit
of commentating during the game. You guys seem to enjoy that. Um,
maybe I'll do commentating during the shittiest most boring parts,
but then I'd have to sit and watch it like whoever's opening and I know sting's
playing the halftime shown as much as I want to go see him and,
and Vinny Collie UDAs on my bucket list.
Like that's not the right band for halftime at the Super Bowl.
Huh?
Every breath you take every day move you made.
He's going to have to go more uptempo shit.
What do you think sting's going to play from his repertoire?
Huh?
It's thing of 10 summer tails,
but that's not the queen of my heart. No, that's not the
Shay of Mar Hall or you can't play that song.
Okay.
Bow Now, but double double bow. Oh, now now what's, I was at boon.
Doga Diego.
Yeah.
Fucking song. We said then there was a song about the brothers
one Betty was a coward. None of that is going to play well.
It probably plays synchronicity. Right? You had a football game.
That's stadium rock. Did you set that goal?
Whoa.
All right. Bunch of old baby boomers. Second along. Bunch of kids go on.
That's not dubstep. Um, they had,
do I want to fast forward through all that shit? Yeah,
I'm thinking about maybe commentating on some of that stuff. I'll just do like,
uh, maybe I'll just do like three minutes of the game, you know,
cause I think it'll get boring after awhile, you know? Um,
at least if I'm going to get bored in myself,
I would think that you guys would get bored. No. Um, all right,
let's plow through here. So I don't have any boots in the fridge, so I'm just,
I guess the month of, uh, I sorta half as committed to this,
like not losing. Is that a bad thing? Fuck is the other,
oh, there it is. Sorry. Um,
talks about everything. Pop Cookie rating out here, Shane. Oh,
I haven't been on the fucking road in weeks, so, um, I might be doing wink,
wink. Oh, I am doing a show this week. That's right.
I'm doing the a d del Reg del Ray at the El Rey.
Oh geesh. I'm a native comedy and Rock,
uh, Dean Del Rey's 50th birthday party. He's going to have, um,
you know, he's going to have Joe Rogan, Krista, Leah, myself. Um,
I know it was a couple of other comics, uh,
red bands gonna be down there and I want to say,
I want to say there's maybe one other comic. And then after that, um, detail,
Ray's gonna front a band, um,
that will include the likes of Rudy Sargasso, Dave Cushner, Dave Lombardo,
uh, Tracy guns, Gilby Clark,
all these rock stars and he's going to sing the entire highway to hell album.
And uh, all Billy red face might sit in for a song or two,
but it's going to be a great night. You can get tickets at, uh,
golden voice dotcom. And also,
um, I might be doing a, a,
a surprise show somewhere locally cause I gotta run my hours.
So when I go to Cheyenne, Wyoming or not get out there,
check out a spread, I want to make sure that they are going to be on my game.
I don't want people in the crowd be like, what the fuck man,
you made us wait to be number 50 for that bull shit walking around.
And they had John Denver fucking cheap coats, right.
Got The sheep lining rocky Matt and had Colorado
Bell. We don't talk like that. We'll talk like this.
That's what Wyoming is all about. I'm going to the Capitol Man.
Do they have open carry in Wyoming? You know,
I made such a big deal about open carry in Texas and uh,
it turns out that they've had it in Oklahoma for years and there hasn't been a
fucking problem. So um, it's kind of a non story.
And then again,
I think that kind of adds to the touristy vibe of going to Texas and seeing
people walking around with holsters. You know, maybe you can see,
have somebody have a fucking shoot out over like a parking parking space,
a duel, right. Draw A,
yeah. Worst case scenario, just a bunch of people that I don't know die,
which is uh, considering with global warming and overpopulation.
I think it's a good thing. I think they should have open carry, uh,
they should have everywhere. Everybody strapped
it would probably actually end up being safer when you think about it.
Cause I know like New York City for as much as everybody talks about how
dangerous it was, uh, I just found on the,
on the subways where all of a sudden you are riding in the car would fucking
everybody, it's all mixed up.
There was a certain level of heightened courtesy because you didn't want to have
a fucking problem. You know, it's the subway, it's New York City.
You could get mugged, you could get the shit kicked out of you.
So people fucking minded their business.
So I would think if you had a whole state of everybody walking around with a gun
on their hip, you know, somebody cuts you off in traffic, you know, Eh,
you know, yeah, I could yell you fucking asshole.
But if you start shooting at me, yeah, it's okay. Go ahead buddy. I mean,
I have a gun too, but you know what?
If I miss and you don't by all means go in front of me. You know,
like if somebody is being weird to you and you're at one of those ATM sits on
the outside of a building. Yeah, it's a very nervous moment for you.
But if you're in your car and that same person cuts you off,
you're fuck fucking kicked the shit out of you.
You fucking ticket and you're all toughing your cock,
which could lead to road rage. Now, if you know that that guy has a gun,
he could just simply, you know,
pointed out the side of his car and just shoot in the general direction of your
car. You figure at the very least he's got to hit the radiator, right?
You have that steam coming up like in every fucking movie, GSD, good old boy.
Right?
You probably got to mind your fucking business.
Yeah.
Maybe that's the secret to ending all wars.
Everybody strapped and you have the gun out.
You just walk in and every time you just walk, you just,
the guns already pointed at somebody. How are you doing? I'm doing good.
How are you? Fine. That's great. Yeah,
keep the conversation short and sweet.
Okay.
I think I just saw ball our, all of our problems, right?
Everybody's strapped with a gloated gun out pointed at somebody's safety off
because you'd be more relaxed, you know,
all they couldn't have safety off cause then when people fell asleep, you know,
it's like falling asleep, you know, smoking, you can let your bed on fire,
you might squeeze off around, which doesn't even make sense, right?
Cause you got to put pressure on it.
Unless you didn't have in one of those dreams. You know,
you have one of those dreams where you're falling or somebody just gives you a
leg sweep, sweep your leg for whatever reason,
and you've got fucking 10 step maybe that, then you shoot yourself in the foot.
I bet podiatrist would be off the bet. They're all for open carry,
you know the foot doctors. All right.
You want me to do some reads for this week here? Let's get into it. Um,
where are we? Come on bill. For God's sakes.
I was on the right one to begin with.
Oh Hey, by the way, does anybody know like when a fucking, for whatever reason,
you download an album off of iTunes and then for whatever reason it just sorta
disappears off of your phone and then fucking reappears because you haven't
hooked it up to the computer. You know what I mean? With phone.
And that makes it legitimately on your phone rather than just going through the
air or whatever the fuck's going on. Right. You know,
cause you got the Wifi on and then the Wifi shuts off and then the album
disappears.
So then your old like may see it downloaded again and then you got that album
and then the, the, the, the first one comes back and now you've got doubles.
How do you get rid of the other one?
I've gone into my iTunes and I've gone to delete it,
but on my phone it's still in double, so I don't know how to do it.
So the song ends and then it replays again. It plays everything twice.
That happened me with van Halen in 1984 and then nas album illmatic it.
Um, as much as I love both of those albums,
I don't need both songs to play twice. How do I get rid of the other one?
If anybody can tell me, I would really appreciate it. All right.
Okay. Kanye situation. Hey Bill,
red blooded American male here who heard about the Kanye situation and was
scared shitless.
I'm not going to disclose whether or not I enjoy what he was accused of enjoying
a parentheses. If you don't know the story,
his ex Amber Rose implied on Twitter that he enjoyed a finger in his ass.
Actually it was fingers plural. Yeah.
I didn't hear about this fucking story and it may be feel good of as a human
being that I was somehow out of the loop of this fucking news.
He said this scared me because it doesn't matter what you're into.
If an ex says shit like that, you're going to get branded. Um,
sir, you sounded like your ex put a vase in your ass.
Yeah.
Anyways, he goes, it's how urban myths about journals get started.
Unless you're fearless Jim Norton and you can say something like that with a
smile on your face, on the airways. It's a pretty tough situation to be in.
How does a man like Kanye deal with that?
Uh, I don't know.
I went, I started to read it, but I don't know. It just,
I don't know if it is true. I don't give a shit not,
it's really none of my business.
Before I could tell from the article he was talking shit about her now hat if
she had half her hand up his fucking assets,
some point is probably not a smart idea if he's sensitive about that part of his
sexuality to be talking Shit.
Right.
Which makes me kind of believe him
that it didn't happen
because you figure if she had that over him,
if she was walking around with them like a sock puppet, right.
That he wouldn't go around talking shit about her.
I Dunno.
I gotta be honest. It's one of those things that I,
I legitimately feel is none of my fucking business.
And, uh,
whether it's true or not doesn't make me look at Kanye one way or the other.
I mean, I don't give a fuck. Give a shit what the guy does.
And I also think a,
I don't think you walk around talking shit about someone who used to go out
with, didn't work out, fucking grow up. You're already married.
You found somebody else leave him alone. Right. I don't know. Look,
I don't know what happened, but all I know he was,
if it's true that he was talking shit about her,
I probably should stop saying talking shit when we're talking about a finger up
your ass. Um, you know, having said all that,
it's fucking hilarious.
Um, okay.
You know,
I would think that there's a lot of rival rappers right now trying to write down
words that rhyme with the phrase fingers up your ass.
Uh hmm.
Lingers in the class with fingers up your ass. I'm sorry.
I don't know that that's,
there's gotta be something that they're coming up with. Oh,
that's an easy one too. If I was,
if I was a rapper and somebody said that my ex put fingers up my ass,
I'll all I would be thinking was like, God damn it. Why didn't she say rectum?
Okay.
At least make it difficult to arrive something. Rectum check.
You checked them fingers up your rectum. Now thing is check the
throw cleaned going up your rectum. Sorry.
Anyways,
um, classes. I like that and I'll hold that to 100% on him.
What about her with this thank you finger stuff. Jesus Christ.
You gotta go with the fist bump. Now when you go with, into,
when you run into amber, give her the ll bug. Want to stay away from that?
Get a fucking tetanus shot. It's funny, she,
she shook her hand and then all of a sudden you just started fucking talking
shit about yourself the way Kanye does. Um, all right. Classes,
uh, in high school. Uh, hello. You Orangutan Looking motherfucker.
I guarantee that this guy is the ugliest motherfucker.
I really find that people, uh, people who trash the way I look the most,
especially on Twitter, never have like their uh, never have their picture.
I don't look like an orangutan do I? They're fucking older.
They look like old people. Um, in a house coat. Uh,
I am a senior in high school. Yeah. Like a kid. Oh, you probably 18.
At this point. Your punk, uh, and this may seem childish to talk about,
but I had been thinking about dropping one of my classes,
this class is music theory,
a p and I'm a straight B studio students, so I'm no genius.
I talked to my teacher and guidance counselor who both said it was fine to drop
it. Music theory being a unique class.
What was that appendix right there at the end there that didn't make,
that was all part of that sentence. Anyways,
recently I came into school thinking, uh, that was the shit.
Like I came into school thinking that this shit was over and I wouldn't have to
take the class anymore,
only to have the assistant principal of my school tell me that I would not be
able to drop at that this point I'm frustrated because I'm very unhappy in the
class and the only ones separating me from dropping the class is my prick of an
assistant principal.
Should I sack up and finish the rest of the year or should I stand up from my
case and become a stubborn prick in the process?
The class gives me anxiety and I'm not really into music anymore.
I'm thinking about picking up a second English class.
If the principal doesn't let me drop the class,
I would probably end up skipping it every day because I hate the class.
That fucking much am I in the wrong? Any advice would be great, Bill. Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself. Um, or when I was a kid, when you went to high school,
you couldn't drop classes that happened in college. You're a senior,
it's February, don't you get out in like the middle of May.
Um, and if you transfer,
do you have to make up the first two semesters or whatever the fuck it is?
September, October, November.
Okay.
December and January worth of shit. And you're second English class.
I just toughed it out. It's music theory. I mean,
that sounds boring as shit. Um, but whatever,
just tough it up.
Okay.
I, I, that's what I would do. I mean,
I mean I would rather tuck up tough. I mean,
I mean maybe just speak my about myself personally,
but I rather tough art music theory than dare take another fucking English
class. But that's me.
Okay.
Yeah, dude, just fucking tough it out.
What's it giving you is anxiety for it? It's a music theory teacher.
It's not like they're going to be like,
so like the football coaches teaching it Izzy. Yeah. Fuck it.
Tough it out.
That seems like a class that even if you just halfway pay attention,
you can at least get a c. Right? I Dunno dude. This fuck it.
It's fucking hangover from this goddamn cookie. I mean,
I fell asleep last night at like six o'clock. I slept for like 12 fucking hours.
I'm still exhausted. All right. Being Stung by shit.
Yeah.
Hey, Billy, big freckle balls. Love that.
You guys think I son my nuts. Uh,
your last podcast touched on being stung by spiders and Shit,
and you touched on sting rays. Uh,
those fucks that killed Steve Irvin and I, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
He fucked with them. And the thing felt like it had to do to defend itself.
All right. I'll tell you right now the,
the rejoicing that wildlife did overall when the crocodile hunter got killed,
I mean, the level of stress that he brought,
every animal that he came into contact with all, see, he's hunching up.
He doesn't like that. The thing is in fear for its fucking life.
And you're going up and you're fucking with the thing.
You know when your little fucking booty shorts. Anyways, he goes,
I'm Canadian and I spent five minutes in an American ocean and was stung by a
sting ray. Well, all of your oceans are American too.
You live in North America. We're all Americans.
But I guess once you say you're Canadian, yeah,
yeah.
Um, United. Okay. I'm a Canadian. I spent five minutes in an American ocean,
was stung by a stingray.
It felt like a hot nail being driven through my foot and the pain went up and up
for hours. It was the most painful thing I've ever experienced. Uh,
let that be a lesson to all the listeners that sting rays are not something to
be fucked with. A nothing can describe that pain. It was insane.
Love the podcast. Fuck you in Boston because they win. So fucking always
cause they win. So fucking always. Um, yeah, we, you know,
this is the thing. We're not supposed to be in the ocean.
Okay?
Okay. I'm going to say that again.
We're not supposed to be in the ocean. We can't breathe in there.
We can't see what's beneath us. We're completely vulnerable when we go in there.
We're not supposed to be in there.
That sting ray has evolved to fuck up things that belong in the ocean,
all of which are way bigger and way faster. Generally speaking,
some giant fish goes to fucking kill this sting ray.
It's got to have enough juice in its shank to make a shark go away.
I would think so. Yeah. You come walking in,
you fucking pink feet. Come walking in there. If you're white, right?
You go in there and you did just yet. It's over subpar.
I'm surprised they don't got enough juice to kill you.
Cause I know Steve Irving,
what happened to him as he got stabbed in the fucking head?
I think it punctured his heart. What are the odds of that?
I wonder what his fucking last thoughts were.
He's both are really fucking sting. Right?
Okay.
Or was he just thinking, oh, let me just pull this out.
I'm sure that'd be fine enough. Oh, that's artery blood. All right.
Love the podcast skill. Fuck. He said, you know, it's funny.
Somebody Australia's can be offended that I'm actually fucking talking like they
haven't thought about this shit. Why isn't it like 10 years ago?
What is the statute of limitations when you, uh,
deliberately go and fuck with a Stinger and get killed by that? It's um,
that you can't keep talking about. All right. Beer drinking contest advice.
Dear Billy Beer Bong. I'm a big fan man.
I to your podcast for a couple of years now and I had the chance to see you
[inaudible] Botnick at the Chicago theater. Great show.
So I've been roped into a beard, beer drinking Olympics,
parentheses for charity by a buddy of mine. And being that I'm an old fuck,
not quite where you are, I'm 38.
I was wondering if you have advice in terms of longevity backstory on me.
I'm a Canadian. I'm Canadian pocket square wearing habs fan.
I know. Fuck me, right? I don't give a shit.
As long as you have a sense of humor about yourself that can really hammer that
back. Beer is my first choice when I drink as I assume as yours.
What would you do to get ready for something like this? Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself. Um, well you gotta I would think,
aren't they going to be different events? You know,
there's got to be drinking beer, there's got to be drinking hard stuff.
Is it all just going to be beer drinking? Wait a second.
I was wondering if you have any advice in terms of longevity. All right.
As far I thought you meant how to, how to live long,
you mean how to hang in there? Um,
well if it's a beer drinking contest,
then I would just drink hard stuff leading up to it, you know,
a couple of beers and had like your shots too, you know, I dunno.
Build up your tolerance.
This doesn't seem like this is a responsible thing for me to be telling you to
do. I would be, I would just go there and have a good time.
That's what I would do. And I wouldn't try to win a medal.
You don't want to be the guy that wins that the guy wins.
That's going to have like fucking rosacea on the side of his face from Booz and
you know, it's going to look like fucking WC fields.
You don't want to be the guy that can win that contest.
I would say just go there. I have a good time, you know, and uh,
stop short of being the guy that fucking pukes all over everybody.
That would be my advice. Uh, alright,
let me do the last reads here really quickly and then I'll do the last question.
I'm fucking trying to shake off this goddamn yawning from that fucking cookie.
I'm like over tired here. Alright. Oh Gay. I,
I've you guys put watching any of the super bowl pregame. Why would you,
are they doing the old man versus the young man
but for the Denver Broncos, Holloway Stopped Cam Newton,
these panthers of the fucking Carolina.
Well,
I'll tell you about cab building is this guy is one of those rare talents that
just can hurt you on every level.
Okay?
He covers receivers. No problem. This guy's got ruddy.
You're going to rush this guy.
You can't bring up Dab with just what guy you're going to stand there and stare
at him. He's going to pick you apart. I'll tell you right now, I void that.
I want to have this job as being a coach. Order these Denver Bronco [inaudible]
Mike, what do you say they're going to do? Who Take the cue?
The Gabe is Deborah has to get to ball and they have to score early.
They got to skill more often.
Their best hope to control Cam Newton is to take the panthers out of their game
plan. If they're playing catch up all night, you know, with dead dead for
[inaudible], you know, I know Peyton Manning's older,
but this is still paid Manny. Okay. It's his last game, man.
I'll tell you right now, he's a competitor.
He's going to get out there and although to pair to each have a good defense,
they still are a young defensive unit. Okay.
And then you'd watch that to come into play,
especially after they make their halftime adjustments.
Is that about it? Something like that. They're gonna try to exploit the seeds.
Um, what about special teams? What about Peyton Manning's wife?
Take an h, g. H what are the odds of that dollar shave club? Everyone,
lots of players will be sporting play off beards.
Now that the post season's here,
can you imagine if Jazelle was getting fucking HGH sent to the house?
I'm sure that story would just disappear after a couple of moments.
Leave that to the pros.
Kickoff your year the right way with a fresh blade shave.
That's why me and when millions of others have joined the dollar shave club.com
revolution.
Dollar Shave Club knows that the key to getting an amazing shave is simple. One,
use a fresh dollar shave club blade to use their doctor cabbies. Easy Shea,
that's it.
Dollar Shave Club delivers amazing razors right to my door for a third of the
price of those gree mega razor corporations.
That means listeners who switched now can afford the luxury of shaving with a
fresh blade anytime and save hundreds this year.
And when you combine that fresh blade with their Dr Cabi Z Z shape
[inaudible],
it just glides. It's unimaginably smooth.
I'm telling you it's not your average shave form. It won't dry out your skin.
The all natural ingredients. Leave your skin feeling soft,
smooth and moisturized after every shape. Take it from me.
Use a fresh dollar shave club blade with doctor cabbies. Easy shave butter.
If you want the most gentle shave imaginable,
join del Shave club.com/bar today.
That's dollar shave club.com/bar. All right, stamps.com every one.
I know what.
Sometimes it feel like sometimes it feels like there's just not enough hours in
the day.
Even when you work or even when you're working past the nine to five that
doesn't make sense,
so it's you're still making time-consuming trips to the post office.
You need a better way. You stamps.com with stamps.com gets postage,
get the postage you need, the instant you needed.
Buy and print official US postage for any letter and package from your computer,
a printer. It's quick and easy. You'll save money with stamps.com too.
It's just a fraction of the cost of one of those expensive postage meters.
Plus you'll get special postage discounts. You can't even find it.
The post office, I use stamps.com to send out all my posters,
whatever I'm pouring myself out right now.
Sign up for stamps.com and use my last name Barbie.
You are our for this special offer,
four week trial plus a $110 bonus offer that includes postage and a digital
scale. Get started with stead. Stop calm today. Today, today.
Within minutes you'll be printing postage, right? Your desk. Go to stance.com.
Before you do anything else, took on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburburthatstamps.com enter bur.
All righty. Mercifully it is ended. Um, all right,
let's get back to, uh,
I got one more read here and then I gotta wrap this fucker up.
Tam For me to go. All right. Dating in the workplace, Aka, no,
geesh. Billy fuckboy bar. Oh Hey. By the way,
I finished the second season of top boy. I highly, uh,
highly recommend it. Um, alright.
There's a lady in my workplace that I have a huge crush on,
but I've fucked everything up by drunkenly telling her best friend at a company
holiday party that I had a crush on, on a,
I say fucked up because I know how females communicate.
I might as well have just walked up to the girl I had a crush on and told her I
know from a past job that dating in the workplace fucks everything else up at
work. I had told myself I'd never do it again,
but for some reason my brain couldn't say no to this girl anyway.
I know this girl knows I like her from her best friend and it made our work
dynamic awkward just because when we interact now,
both of us feel like we have to fulfill some sort of role.
Well, he should have just walked up to it says, Hey, I got a little drunk.
I said some things to your girlfriend, uh, that you know,
I should've said to you that I can't say that that's too forward. Oh,
the office just makes it creepy.
You can't lean on anything as you're talking to her,
you might as well just be standing there rubbing your balls. Ah, this,
this situation. One day I said fuck it,
and half aster route to an art museum.
But she had friends in town said she couldn't.
What pisses me off is that I used to hang out with my coworkers and this girl
every now and then now, no, no one invites me to hang out.
When they do a background on the company,
it's under a hundred people and we're all in our twenties for the most part. Uh,
what's the best way to pursue this girl in this situation and how do I mentally
handle the fact that it's affected my ability to hang out with my coworkers,
my other coworkers, I really want closure to this thing, whether it be a date,
whether I date her or she tells me she's done interested.
I don't care at this point. I really don't like the tension at work. Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself. Yeah. Which says to me,
you don't really even like this girl Mike.
I just want to ask around and get rid of the tension. And then she says yes.
So she says, no, I really don't give a fuck at this moment. This is what you do.
This is what you do, sir. You just just fucking blow it off.
Just blow it off. You don't give a shit. Just act normal around her. All right?
Then she'll be gone. Like, oh he doesn't give a fuck.
And then she'll probably end up being interested in you.
Cause that's how they fucking work. All right? Don't,
don't hang out with the people you work with. Fuck someone you don't work with.
You need to create a social circle outside of work.
The people at work should be the people you see Monday through Friday. Okay?
And then once Friday, see you later guys. Take it easy. What are you doing?
I'm getting the fuck away from you, right? Then you go out,
you can do your fucking black tar heroin or whatever the fuck you want to do.
And then there's no awkwardness at the copier. All right?
You already said you've, you've,
you fuck somebody that you worked with before and how that made your last job
awkward yet. Here you go again.
And for some reason you're not even in a relationship yet and it's already
fucking up your coat. You're a,
yeah,
just your,
your interaction with your coworkers yet you want to pursue this thing too.
I would just let it go. Just let it go. And uh,
listen.
You want to fuck somebody at work? Don't try and fuck them. All right.
Just come in with a big smile on your face on Monday and every, you know,
nobody knows what the fuck you did. And they're all hanging out with each other,
they're all gossiping with each other and eventually they going to be gossiping
about you. Hey, I wonder what he does, what's up with his exciting life?
You know,
and you're coming in looking like you're out there banging away and fucking
having a great time going out in the town.
Eventually one of these brides is going to be fucking interested enough and then
you know what?
Your dumb ass is going to fuck her and then it's going to be awkward again.
Can't do it to it. You gotta you gotta have a fucking your social sir.
You're fucking, and you're drinking and all that has to be outside of work. Um,
unless it's a guy, okay, it cannot be,
cannot fucking hang with women that you work with. You can't do it.
Cause eventually your Dick's going to make you say something stupid.
Something's going to happen.
Well that's going to get in the fucking way and it's just going to be a big be a
big God damn problem. Uh, same thing. Don't hang out with your boss either.
Hang out with somebody that's on your fucking level. Even then, dude,
I wouldn't, I wouldn't hang out. You don't hang out with people you work with.
You know, something always ends up happening.
Maybe it do something dumb and then your buddy can't keep his fucking mouth
shut. You know, and then it gets to somebody and then that you're up for your,
your, your review. You don't get as much money. You get passed over.
It's fucking stupid. You're in your twenties. You're to make a,
you're gonna make a bunch of fucking mistakes.
So don't do it with the people you work with. Alright.
Have I said that enough times? Alright, haven't said that.
Okay.
Um, you want my Superbowl pick? Um,
I actually liked the Broncos with the points.
If they get getting six and don't listen to me because I don't know anything
about the Broncos coach,
but I know bill Belichick with Peyton manning in that defense could figure out a
way to uh, beat the Carolina Panthers.
And I know a lot of you guys are thinking,
well that defense and that coach and Peyton manning just beat you patriots and
bill Belicheck. It's like, well he didn't have the team, you know.
Um,
my only concern is that Denver's defense isn't as good as it looked against the
patriots because a, we had that Swiss cheese fucking offensive line.
We had injuries all that year and Carolina, it looks really healthy.
Their offensive line looks really healthy. So, uh,
I dunno,
I think that bullshit that I actually said earlier where I was making fun of
those analysis,
those analysts is actually what I think dead for better hope that when the toss,
and I would say take the ball rather than deferring it and hopefully you marched
down the field score seven, give them a three and out.
I think I literally think that they then need to score again. Go up 10. Nothing.
This is my keys to the game. Denver when the toss,
they need to go out there and somehow get it Todd and choose heads.
If it's going to be heads, tails, if it's going to be tails, then they gotta
take the fucking ball, ram it down their fucking throats. Yeah.
Just obvious shit.
Nice time consuming drive and uh,
stablish the run. Um,
I think Peyton could do all right against the defense if they, if they, uh,
you know, if he has the fucking time,
see there's no way to say really bill, what if he doesn't have the time?
Does that make it more difficult? This is really hard. This is really,
it's really hard to say something that isn't cliched. Um,
my, my concern is a Broncos fan is that PR the panthers get the ball,
they march right down the field and they score it because what's his face?
Peyton manning is his gloom and doom guy.
That guy gets that look on his face. Peyton faces what?
Me and my family used to call it where he just see just purses,
his lips and he starts looking down field shaking his head as he takes his
fucking Chin strap off after yet another three and out.
That's the, that's the the headspace.
Panthers want to get him and he gets into the eye. He gets into that.
And why isn't everybody as good as me mindset. It's fucking over.
So in order to keep him happy, I'd say that they got a score.
I'm back to that again. That Jesus,
maybe I'll come up with something on Thursday. There you go. Everybody.
[inaudible] I'd take the Broncos in the points. I'd take six points. Fuck it.
Cause every contact is going to take the panthers.
Every [inaudible] out there is going do to,
parents are going to fucking destroy them.
That's when you want to go the other way because what that means that every
fucking shit head out there is going to put money on the panties,
which means the line will keep going up because Vegas is one. Again,
this is going to want to get money on both sides of the ball. Thank you, Bill.
Like we didn't know that. I'll fuck you. I'll talk to you guys on Thursday.
Go fuck yourselves. And um, don't fuck anybody you work with.